It seems that the only consequence for
Nvidia's actions, which I think are
deceitful, is more money.
That's the consequence. They get more
money. It's working.
This is Nvidia's newest chart filled
with, by our belief, actual lies. This
deceitful chart filled with manipulative
[__] represents the RTX 5060 as
being 90x better on the nebulous
relative scale with the 4060 at 45X.
seemingly with the GTX 1050 at 1x
resulting in a 5060 that's 9,000% better
than a 1050 and a 3050 with DLSS that's
somehow significantly better than an RTX
560 without DLSS which absolutely is not
true in any possible way. Nvidia has
contorted itself in such a way that its
own worse older cards somehow look
better than its new ones. Better still,
there's two 3050s and they don't specify
which one it is in that chart even
though they are different products. And
this is exactly what we believe Nvidia
wants reviewers to do with their charts
and it's what we spoke out against back
in May of this year. Now, Nvidia today
has taken a few more grains of sand off
the beach to manufacture its latest
round of e-waste, manipulatively named
the RTX 5050. Even though it'll probably
barely be able to handle rasterized
games, let alone real-time ray traced
ones. At a baffling $250 and excessive
130 watts, the RTX 5050 fails to do
anything that the prior 50 class cards
did. Its power consumption is too high
to utilize without a power connector, so
that eliminates that use case. and its
price is too high to make more sense
than a used card for the same price.
Right now, sold eBay listings show an
RTX 2080 Ti 11 gigabyte GPU for $250,
the same price that the 5050 won't be
available at. Or perhaps you'd prefer
the RTX 3080 Top for $300, probably the
price of some of the 5050 partner
models, or an AMD RX6700 XT for $210. an
AMD RX6816 GB for $295, still with a
warranty, or an RTX 4060 for $228, a
3070Ti for $250, or any number of other
GPUs, including new ones like the B580
from Intel, also listed for $250 to
$300. The point is, nobody should buy
the trash that Nvidia just announced.
Nvidia's own blog post talks about how
the 50cl class cards are desired for the
power consumption being low, and yet
this one requires an 8 pin power
connector and pulls 130 watts. This
already kills a potential use case of
these low-end cards, which is a GPU that
doesn't need a power cable like the old
GTX 750. Then again, the 750 was low
enough TDP that there were even passive
models available. The RTX 5050 has 2560
CUDA cores that are at least black while
generation. The card advertises a 2.57
GHz boost clock and a 2.31 GHz base with
the memory of 8 GB on a 128 bit bus.
Some historical data would help. And so
what we've put together today is a bunch
of charts. We're going to flash through
them really quickly that show the MSRP
inflation adjusted prices. We'll show
CUDA versus memory bandwidth on the
cards over time. We'll look at some
benchmarks and we'll even look at some
of Nvidia's propaganda. So, let's get
into all of that. We brought you this
video with store.gamersacus.net and a
special commemorative relaunch of our
original Modmat design. We haven't made
this design in about 4 years now, but
some of you have been asking us to
re-release it. We're posting these on
the store now as what is likely our last
run of the first ever GN modmat design
that we introduced originally in 2017.
Of course, we still have the GN15
designs in stock if you want to grab one
of the newest versions of the modmat.
This new run of the first modmat
involves our newer and more advanced
printing and QC processes, improving
upon the original production runs
starting in 2017. The design features
the GN tearown style logo, a large GPU
screw tracking grid, a pinout diagram
for common power connectors, and also
includes a common ground point and wrist
strap. We also just recently restocked
more of our copper plated stainless
steel mule mugs with thermal
conductivity on them. So, head over to
store.gamersex.net to grab the mule mugs
or the limited rerun of the original
Modmat design. Thanks for your support.
Let's start with some of the numbers.
This shows the MSRP and inflation
adjusted prices of the 50 series dating
back to about 2009. Price has clearly
climbed significantly in the last two
generations. The average MSRP for this
card going back 16 years is $157 or $196
when adjusted for inflation. When
eliminating the 50/50 and the 3050, the
average inflation adjusted launch price
is $180. So, it's clearly getting more
expensive. And we think that Nvidia's
data for that earlier relative scaling
chart should be used as a piece of
evidence in the next action against it.
But there's more to this. This chart
shows the percentage of cores that a
50cl class card has against the 60class
counterpart as measured against the
percent of the price that the 50 class
is of the 60class. In other words, the
RTX 5050 is 83.3% of the MSRP of the RTX
5060 and yet only 67% of the CUDA core
count. We've never seen numbers this bad
from Nvidia with this series of low-end
hardware. The GTX 1050 that Nvidia
claims a 9,000% improvement against was
43.6% of the price of the GTX 1069 FE
with 50% of the CUDA core hardware. The
1650 versus 2060 was similar. The GTX
650 might have been the last era that
was as offbalance against consumers as
the 5050 is, but that was back when
Nvidia released multiple 50class cards
with the 650Ti and 60Ti boost. This
chart shows the bandwidth versus the
price. With the 5050, you're paying 83%
of a 5060 for 71% of the bandwidth. This
has been getting worse since the 3050s,
but before that, it was better. the 1650
versus the 1660 at about a 67.7% of the
price to 66.6% bandwidth ratio or 42.6%
of the 2060 price for 38.1% of the
bandwidth. These are closer to or even
at par. Going back further, the GTX 1050
was 43.6% of the price of a GTX 1060,
but with 58.3% of the bandwidth. The GTX
950 was also favorable at 79.5% of the
price for 94.3% of the bandwidth. And
one of the things that Nvidia is doing
is leaning on these relative charts to
show how much better their new GPUs are
than sometimes their other new GPUs by
accident. But that's that's how relative
scaling works. Unfortunately for Nvidia,
it goes both ways. And so we made our
own relative charts. Maybe this chart
shows it best. This shows Nvidia's cards
by CUDARE count percentage relative to
the flagship. If they can do it, we can
do it too. We defined the methodology
for how we track 90class, Titan class,
EIclass cards in our Nvidia
shrinkflation video. That video defines
how this chart is made and what choices
we make when there are multiple choices.
The new RTX 5050 is the worst GPU that
Nvidia has launched in any GTX or RTX
card series on this chart, meaning not
counting the GTs or GTS. It has 12% of
CUDA core count of the flagship. Now,
you could argue that this is in part
because the flagships have gotten
better, and that's true. But at the same
time, everything else has failed to
scale with them or gotten worse while
getting more expensive. The 50/50 is
another of those cards. In fact, even
the 5060 is more similar to a 1050 than
a 50/50 is. And if you want a card just
for end code and decode or something, it
might be time to seriously consider
Intel or maybe at least consider using
an RC card as like an accelerator or
something. We'll talk about that more in
the future. And for gaming, we'll bring
it back to used. It's time to seriously
consider options like those we spoke
about earlier. Make sure they're sold
working, not just for parts, but it's
normally listed and you can get better
cards for cheaper. Let's take a look at
some charts without the 50/50 to see
what an onslaught it's going to be when
the 50/50 is added to those charts. And
we are going to buy one and we are going
to add it to the charts because buying
the RTX Pro 6000 wasn't a problem. So,
buying the 5050 probably won't be a
problem. Nvidia's own RTX 3060Ti has
done well to show how ridiculous the
newer cards look. These charts are from
our 5060 review where the 3060 Ti is
about equivalent to the 5060 with the
4060 different by singledigit
percentages. Or this chart where the
5060 is nearly tied with the 6700 XT
that can be had for about the same price
as a 50/50 on the used market, has more
VRAM and actually is fast enough to use
it. or take a look at the 3080 here,
which runs at 5060Ti and 4070 levels.
Multiframe generation cannot bring a
50/50 to this experience. It is at best
a smoothing technology, and we have
videos about that. And then there's the
2080 Ti in this chart, which has it
below the 3070 Ti, which we found sold
listings for, working for $250 on eBay.
That's for the 3070 Ti. A 50/50 is not
going to be able to run this test at
all. So if we want to play [__]
relative number games, we can do that.
Our chart will have other cards, mostly
used ones, at infinity and the 50/50 at
zero because you can't divide by zero.
So I've decided that means infinity.
Isn't stat math for marketing fun? And
we can produce more charts to prove the
same point repeatedly. But what we're
going to do is save that for our 50/50
review and produce probably 20 to 25
minutes of those charts proving the same
point repeatedly. So you can check back
for that. Now all this comes at a time
when Nvidia is experimenting. It's grown
up now. It's become a big boy and it's a
real monopoly. So it's playing around
currently somewhere in the range of
that. Sure is a nice engineering
interview you have there. It'd be a
shame if something happened to it and
experimenting with providing drivers
only to so-called reviewers who will
produce preview pieces under strict
guidelines like for the 560 launch.
Propagandizing for Nvidia is the new
thing. We've seen it since May. So, in
our opinion, Games Radar, which is owned
by the same publisher that owns PC
Gamer, Tom's Guide, and Tom's Hardware,
was complicit in Nvidia's propaganda
when it received early driver access at
a time when Nvidia was actively
preventing independent reviewers from
testing its 5060. Games Radar said the
5060 quote, "Feels pretty slick for
under $300 and quote, in its coverage
with limitations seemingly dictated by
Nvidia." Not to mention that it's
deceptive to call $299.99
quote under $300, especially when that
often is actually above $300. Tom's
Guide, also owned by Future Publishing,
published an aligned indoctrination
campaign in our opinions on the same day
as sister publication Games Radar,
stating, quote, "Spoiler alert. When
tested under Nvidia scenarios, the games
live up to and in some cases slightly
exceed the company's performance
claims." End quote. That is as clear as
day to us. It says Nvidia's scenarios.
Tom's guide also said, quote, "You're
going to have a great time at 1080p with
DLSS4 being the backbone to all of it."
End quote. In its again what we think is
a complicit PR campaign with Nvidia.
GameStar Tech in Germany also ran an
article with driver access when other
reviewers who had the 5060 were blocked
from testing, stating via machine
translation, quote, "Nvidia gave us the
opportunity to run benchmarks under
specific conditions ahead of the RTX
560's release." End quote. GameStar
defines the restrictions, which is
actually pretty useful for us. Here it
says this quote, "Only measurements of
the RTX 560, 3060, and 2060 Super are
permitted. We are only allowed to run
benchmarks in the five games, Avowoud,
Doom Dark Ages, Marvel Rivals, Cyberpunk
2077, and Hogwarts Legacy. Both the
resolution, 1080p, and the graphic
settings are fixed, a crucial factor
here. While the RTX 560 can utilize
quadruple multiframe generation, older
GPUs don't allow additional frames to be
generated using AI." End quote. This is
my opinion, but this is your future.
I'll be fine. We have other things we
review. We're ramping on our
investigations, our special reports. We
have the case reviews. We've been doing
factory tours and educational content.
We're good. We have content to produce.
And we'll even still review Nvidia GPUs.
What I'm worried about is that this has
now gone beyond marketing. We are at a
point where Nvidia is, in my opinion,
actively attempting to deceive
consumers, not just marketing deception.
That's what I think this is. And I think
it's abusing its market position. It has
92% market share. Now, Nvidia is
actively damaging the enthusiast and
gaming industries and hobbies. And this
is something that not just I think
speaking with a lot of other companies
in the space and we'll have something on
this in the future. Uh one of the things
that we've come to appreciate is that
the companies that don't even make video
cards as in not even the partners of
Nvidia also share these feelings and
we'll talk about that in the future. But
as of now Nvidia is a monopoly. It is
that simple. And now rather than simply
enjoy their monopoly with their 92%
market share, Nvidia it seems, chooses
to exploit the littlest guy in its
customer base, the end user. And Nvidia
is doing so not only by weaponizing
friendly media into a propaganda
machine, but also by straight up lying
to its customers, I think, about their
performance. If the GTX 1050 runs at 12
FPS in a game, even with MFG4X, the 5060
would have to run at 1,100 FPS to be 90x
better than it. That's assuming this is
even based on something halfway
reasonable and not just loading the 1050
to a point where it literally can't run
the game. But we're not here to defend
the 1050's honor because I don't care
about it. And this is a stupid
comparison anyway. And that is because
the stupidest thing on Nvidia's chart
has to be the 3050 with DLSS
outperforming its own 5060 with it off
or the fact that they chose not to put a
5080 on here because they're carefully
concocted [__] would yield the 3050
with DLSS outperforming the 5080 stock.
This is another one of the times in my
career where I've been genuinely mad
about how a company is treating
consumers. And I'm not talking this
isn't like YouTube we're doing it for
the memes mad. Like this isn't
engagement mad. I am genuinely mad about
how Nvidia is treating people. And the
reason is they are I think abusing their
market position and there's nothing
anybody can do about it. If you want to
compete with Nvidia, go ahead, take a
look at Intel. How's that been going for
them? It's taken a while to even start
to get off the ground. And they needed
billions upon billions of dollars of
assets and employees and knowhow to even
get started with it. And this is a
situation where it can feel relatively
powerless. I mean, there is some power
in choosing what to buy, but they have
over 90% of the market. They've got a
lock on things that require CUDA. I can
barely do my job without CUDA because of
Adobe software. That's not something I
control. I mean, there's things we've
experimented with, but you get the
point. It's just that Nvidia is so
doineering that even when you're upset,
look at our own recommendations in this
video. Go buy a used Nvidia GPU.
There's some used AMD ones out there,
too. The 6800, the 6700 XT, the 7700 XT
is not bad for the price when it's used.
But the point being that almost anywhere
you look, all roads do appear to go at
least towards Nvidia. They might not end
there. They might end at [__] this, I'm
buying a console. But a lot of them go
there. And so yes, for this I am
actually mad about it. And it's not for
the camera mad. It is mad. I mean, it's
to the point where when I'm walking
around, not at work, this is bothering
me. And the part that bothers me is
Nvidia's abuse of its position. And that
it seems the only consequence for
Nvidia's actions. And here what we're
talking about today to remind you is
continuing to manipulate the stack of
cards to make them look better than they
are and to play these games with things
like this relative performance scaling
chart that will trick a lot of typical
end users, people who don't follow this
stuff. But the thing that bothers me is
that it is actively damaging the scene.
And it seems that the only consequence
for Nvidia's actions, which I think are
deceitful, is more money.
That's the consequence. They get more
money. It's working. So, we'll test the
50/50. I look forward to calling it a
waste of sand or DOA or saying don't buy
or whatever. And I know that's what it's
going to be because I can look at the
specs and the price and I know what the
conclusion is. It's easy to predict. We
also look forward to testing Nvidia's
claims. But for us, even without testing
it, we'd recommend a used card at the
same price. Recommending used cards is
worse for us in one way because we don't
make affiliate revenue from that. But
I'd rather have people actually excited
to build computers and enjoy them the
way that I have gotten to enjoy them for
the last couple decades. And in so
doing, getting GPUs that they don't feel
ripped off about or that they don't feel
leaves a bad taste in their mouth after
buying. And I'd rather forfeit that
affiliate revenue and people do that
than turn into a feckless shill from a
propaganda outlet like what Future
Publishing was doing with Ninvidia in my
opinion. So that is where we are at this
point. Nvidia,
it's going to get worse. Like this is
the future.
It's a question of how much the media
will play these games with Nvidia. And
there are outlets that I trust will
continue to be holdouts and will
continue to do the right thing for
consumers. to name one of them. Hardware
unboxed. We just met with him at Compyex
about a month ago and did a couple
videos. But the point being, you know,
we're going to keep reviewing these
cards. We'll buy them. Uh again, people
like Hub will continue to review the
cards and there'll be content out there.
It's just like this is this was kind of
a news video about the 50-50, but it's
also just look at
look at what they've done to my boy.
Look at what they've done to PC gaming.
I think that's what this turned into as
I started writing the announcement of
the 5050 and um it's bad. This is not
this is not in a good place like that
Nvidia can produce the kinds of
materials it is producing. It's not
enough to just be in control and be able
to sell every [__] thing they make.
They have to then go ahead and put
together these charts that again I think
effectively lie actively about what it
does.
If you're going to sell it anyway, just
sell it. Like I said last time, don't
drag the whole industry down into your
[__] Nvidia, that's it for this
one. Subscribe for more. Go to
store.gamersac.net to support us
directly. patreon.com/gamers nexus. And
we'll see you all next